BEEN ARRESTED, THEIR WHEREABOUTS
ARE STILL UNKNOWN.
IF THE PENTAGON CONSIDERING A
PLAN TO ADD UP TO 7,000
ADDITIONAL U.S. FORCES TO THE
MIDDLE EAST A COUNTER WENT
EXCEEDS AS    AS A INCREASING TR
EXCEEDS AS    AS A INCREASING TA
EXCEEDS AS    AS A INCREASING TT
FROM IRAN.
I WILL ASK THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR ABOUT THAT IN JUST A
BIT.
PENTAGON'S TOP POLICY ADVISOR
SAYS THAT DEFENSE SECRETARY HAS
NOT OFFICIALLY MADE ANY
DECISION.
IF TONIGHT, STATE DEPARTMENT IS
PUTTING A VERY LARGE NUMBER ON T
PUTTING A VERY LARGE NUMBER ON E
TOTAL OF IRANIAN CIVILIANS
KILLED IN MASS DEMONSTRATIONS
THERE OVER THE HIKING GASOLINE
PRICES.
LEARNING ABOUT YOU AND SEIZURE
ALSO AS MISSILE PARTS ALLEGEDLY
BEEN STRUGGLED TO THE REBELS.
REPORTING ON AROUND TONIGHT FROM
LISBON, PORTUGAL.
>> OVERNIGHT, THE U.S. NAVY
REPORTED SEIZING A CACHE OF
IRANIAN MISSILE PARTS SEEING YOU
MIKE DILLARD
REBELS.
THEY WORK TOWARD THE JOINT
DEFENSE AGREEMENT.
TRAVELING TO PORTUGAL ON
WEDNESDAY TO MEET WITH U.S.
SECRETARY OF STATE OF
MIKE POMPEO.
TO DISCUSS RISING
TENSIONS WITH IRAN.
>> WE SEE THEM TOTTER AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO INCREASE
THE PRESSURE AGAINST IRANIAN
AGGRESSION.
>> DESPITE THEIR ADMINISTRATION
TO DISENGAGE FROM THE
MIDDLE EAST, THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN AMERICANS AND IRANIANS R
BETWEEN AMERICANS AND IRANIANS M
BETWEEN AMERICANS AND IRANIANS I
BETWEEN AMERICANS AND IRANIANS N
STRONG.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SUGGESTED
TODAY THAT MORE THAN 1,000
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED BY
GOVERNMENT FORCES IN THE ONGOING
IRANIAN PROTESTS.
>> AMERICA WILL ALWAYS STAND
WITH THE IRANIAN PEOPLE IN THE
RIGHT TO STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM.
>> IRAN'S FOREIGN MINISTER TODAY
CALLED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMENTS ABOUT U.S. SANCTIONED
AGAINST IRAN AND ADMISSION OF
"ECONOMIC TERRORISM."
THEY FLIGHTS WERE A MERGER
CONFLICT AND THEY GO TOWARDS
NEGOTIATIONS.
>> IF THERE ARE REALLY READY TO
LIFT THE SECTIONS WE ARE READY
TO TALK AND WE DECLARE
THAT BEFORE.
>> REPORT TODAY SAYS THAT IRAN
IS BUILDING A MISSILE STOCKPILE
IN IRAQ THAT COULD THREATEN
SAUDI ARABIA, ISRAEL, AND U.S.
TROOPS IN THEIR REGION.
AIR STRIKES TARGETED A SEPARATE
WEAPONS STOCKPILE IN EASTERN
SYRIA.
WHETHER ISRAEL WAS BEHIND THE
STRIKE, PRIME MINISTER TOLD FOX